nous sommes le 13 février 1960 une bombe
au plutonium plus puissante que celle
d'hiroshima explose à reggane dans le
sahara algérien baptisé gerboise bleue
cette opération est le premier essai
nucléaire de la france et concrétise le
voeu du général de gaulle formulée dès
1945 est de rejoindre le club des
puissances disposant la bombe atomique
avec les états unis et l'urss ces autres
essais auront lieu par la suite entre
1960 et 1966 sur les sites de reggane et
puis est d'in eker pendant quatre ans et
conformément aux accords d'evian et qui
acte et l'indépendance de l'algérie la
france a continué à utiliser jusqu'en
1967 les sites du sahara pour ses essais
nucléaires
les conséquences sur les populations
locales et l'environnement sont devenus
un sujet de contentieux entre la france
et l'algérie
celle ci demande à son ancienne
puissance coloniale d'en prendre acte et
d'agir en conséquence
la france doit assumer ses
responsabilités historiques surtout
après que 122 états de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu ont ratifié le 7
juillet 2017 nouveau traité sur
l'interdiction des armes nucléaires qui
vient s'ajouter aux traités antérieurs
le principe du pollueur payeur qui a été
d'ailleurs introduit et reconnue
officiellement
c'est la première fois que la communauté
internationale demande aux puissances
nucléaires de rectifier les erreurs du
passé
soixante et un ans plus tard le général
bout fria réclame à la france au nom de
l'algérie de remettre les cartes de
localisation des déchets nucléaires et
de décontaminer les sites toujours
potentiellement nocifs
sans oublier l'indemnisation des
victimes des souvenirs à douloureux est
teintée d'émotion qui persistent dans
les mémoires pour les habitants de
reggane il était 7 heures du matin nous
avons senti la terre bouger sous nos
pieds
c'était l'heure de la prière quand je
suis sorti de chez moi il y avait une
fumée blanche dans le ciel du jamais vu
cette lumière est resté pendant trois
jours les gens qui avaient des bêtes les
ont vus devenir aveugle à cause de cette
lumière
je n'oublierai jamais la frayeur causée
par la bombe aucune étude sérieuse
montre à ce jour les répercussions
écologiques et sanitaires de ces essais
nucléaires
entre 1900 et 1966 mais pour le
professeur mustapha baouchi doom
responsable des maladies cancéreuses de
l'hôpital d'adrar et installé dans la
région depuis 30 ans l existence de
plusieurs pâtés logique qui ont été
observés pourraient être liés à ces
essais 29 pathologie au total qui serait
susceptible d'avoir comme cause la
radioactivité due à une explosion
atomique des probabilités selon les
termes à du docteur ouchy d'où une
difficulté pour les victimes qui
souhaiteraient porter l affaire devant
les instances internationales certains
algériens parlent même de crime contre
l'humanité
concernant ce que dit macro et les
crimes importante de la france en
algérie nous en tant qu'algérien nous
devons avoir une position unifiée entre
le peuple et le gouvernement contre
macro et la france pour les obliger à
reconnaître les crimes commis en algérie
est très grand crime les crimes contre
l'humanité sans précédent dans le monde
lundi 8 février le gouvernement algérien
a réagi via son porte parole en
demandant à la france une nouvelle fois
de reconnaître ses crimes coloniaux et
pourtant en février 2010 est le candidat
à maquereau en déplacement en algérie
avait reconnu la demande algérienne est
acté la nécessité d'une repentance
une attitude qui a évolué pendant 200 le
costume de chef d'état adou la demande
en juillet 2020 d'un rapport à
l'historien benjamin stora sur la
réconciliation mémorielle entre
l'algérie et la france a déposé le 21
janvier dernier emmanuel macron s'est
engagé à prendre des actes symboliques
pour apaiser les mémoires mais a exclu
de présenter les excuses demandées par
alger la réconciliation a donc encore
beaucoup de chemin devant elle